und zwar wichtig heute geht über natalia
wörner die schauspielerin und die
lebensgefährtin von unserem
außenminister heiko matz und natalia
wörner in einem interview mit der bild
am sonntag gesagt dass sie nicht mit
ungeimpften drehen würde ich frage mich
wirklich geht's wo sind wir angekommen
in unserer zeit dass jetzt eine
schauspielerin mit dieser aussage
eigentlich will dass ungeimpfte
arbeitsverbot haben wir werden sie nicht
mit ungeimpften drehen will und ich
meine natalia wörner ist ja schon der
star einer jeden produktion da kann ich
mir schon vorstellen sich auch
durchsetzt das muss man sagen ein
produktionsbudget stark getestet testen
ist auch wichtig als zum beispiel die
produktion jeden tag in schnelltest und
dann noch jeden zweiten tag den pcr test
der teil der berner ist es aber nicht
genug wie gesagt für ungeimpfte gibt es
keine dreharbeiten mir auf jeden fall
nicht wo sie teilnimmt sie wenig mit
ungeimpften drehen
und damit herzlich willkommen wie ist
denn ihr die meinung franziska was sagst
du ja erst mal vielen dank dass ich hier
sein darf heute ich freue mich sehr über
diesen schon ausgeguckt und deshalb
erzählt zu sein ist ganz verrückt erst
einmal ich würde überhaupt nicht
zustimmen ehrlich gesagt ich bin
persönlich der meinung es gibt einmal
das wird ja mal angefordert eine
freiheit für ungeimpfte solange sie sich
testen lassen und sicherstellen können
dass sie keine gefahr für andere
menschen sind sollten sie frei
entscheidung treffen dürfen wir haben
hier keine impfpflicht aber auf der
anderen seite gibt es auch eine freiheit
für im geimpfte auch eigene entscheidung
darüber zu treffen mit wem sie
zusammenarbeiten wollen und deshalb ich
persönlich bin ein großer fan vom testen
ich habe keine angst mich mit menschen
zum geben die nicht geimpft insofern sie
sich sehr regelmäßig testen aber ich
finde das ist eine freie entscheidung
die sie auch trifft und endlich gesagt
finde ich das muss man respektieren und
einen punkt möchte ich auch noch dazu
machen ich finde sehr schwierig von
einem arbeitspapier zu sprechen erstens
ist es kann aber als verbot das ist eine
entscheidung die sie trifft und die sie
auch meiner meinung nach eben frei
treffen können solche arbeitsverbot das
erinnert mich ehrlich gesagt an den
umgang der nazis mit juden und ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ist schockiert mich
und es ist wirklich entgeistert mich zu
sehen dass viele corona und impfgegner
mit judenstern durch demonstration gehen
und versuchen zu insinuieren sie werden
genauso ausgegrenzt und stigmatisiert
juden damals im dritten reich und das
finde ich wirklich
wirklich ekelhaft und davon möchte ich
mich auf jeden fall distanzieren deshalb
ich finde das wort kein spiel richtig
würde sagen da sollte man es auf jeden
fall von verabschieden und ich glaube es
gibt keine frage eine frage franz km
beim ersten mal bin ich nicht bei dir
bei dem vergleich übrigens mit dem
holocaust wenn ich eins zu eins beide
diese zeit sollte man mit nichts in der
welt vergleichen da sind wir genau auf
einer linie aber wie kann es denn dann
als alle dem zum beispiel restaurants
hat nicht mehr arbeiten durften also für
mich gehört das wort nicht dieser zeit
die zeit der gehört ja nicht das wort
weil ich fand in der zeit von den lockt
uns gab es ein arbeitsverbot für kellner
für restaurantbesitzer würde ich das
nicht als arbeitsverbot bezeichnen ich
glaube es was ganz unterschiedliches was
jetzt als thema heute mitgebracht wurde
da geht es ja um ein mensch der selber
entscheidet das ist jetzt kein
arbeitsverbot durch den staat oder so
sondern dass ein mensch entscheidet ich
persönlich ich möchte nicht mit jemanden
zusammenarbeiten der sich nicht geimpft
hat und der ich bin für mich da nicht
sicher genug und ich finde das muss man
respektieren und das online nach einem
locker und war es ein arbeitsverbot das
war ein look down in dem menschen nicht
arbeiten konnten aber es kann
arbeitspapier das war ja auch andere
dinge verboten also selbst nicht konkret
hat sich nicht bestimmt ganz konkret auf
das arbeiten bezogen sondern auf
allgemein das zuhause bleiben also ich
weiß nicht ich habe jetzt keine angst
vor dem begriff arbeitsverbot so ist es
nicht ich glaube das sollte man auch
nicht haben aber ich glaube das wort
quasi zu überhöhen und zu sagen das ist
alles ja ich finde diese rhetorische
auffassung der schwierig und ich glaube
ehrlich gesagt auch dass auch viele
menschen davon abhält dann am ende sich
dann doch impfen zu lassen und ich
glaube das gibt entsteht auch eine
bestimmte hysterie und dass wir teile
ich das hat nicht und da würde ich dir
deshalb widersprechen die runde weiter
zu unterstützen also ich finde einfach
es war natürlich ein eingriff in die
möglichkeit zu arbeiten auch in die
berufsfreiheit die verfassungsmäßig
garantierte ist was war ein objektiver
eingriff das heißt das lag nicht daran
dass es jetzt nena war die da arbeiten
wollt oder johannes was lag hat jetzt
daran dass
also aus gewissen infekt ausland nun
mein vergleich um genau zeigen dass
arbeits wurden nicht den holocaust denke
ich muss meine davon ich finde aber
natalia wörner das verhalten auch
verantwortungsvoll für sich
verantwortungsvoll enthalten die sie für
sich trifft und ich finde jetzt keine
diskriminierung ihrer kollegen also weil
ihre entscheidung hat auf die kollegen
und die möglichkeiten der kollegen zu
arbeiten dass man sich keinen einfluss
weil die regeln werden vom staat gemacht
sind für alle gleich und scheint sich
natalia wörner aber was heißt das jetzt
dass natalia wörner keine filme mehr
dreht heißt es dass weil doch jeder
fünfte in der gesellschaft nach wie vor
nicht geimpft ist und mir war es also
die frage habe ich mich sofort gestellt
als die bams gelesen habe am sonntag ist
es überhaupt natalia wörner die
entscheidet wer da am set mit dreht und
nicht als sie es doch schauspielerin
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
also ist es bei ihnen zum beispiel in
der spd fraktion so dass sie sagen
können also bei dem möchte ich der ist
ungeimpft es wird vermutlich nämlich
auch ungeimpfte in der spd fraktion
geben von dem möchte ich nicht mehr dass
der in der spd-fraktion mit dem möchte
ich nicht mehr dass der mitspielt wir
werden das erleben dass wir in den
nächsten tagen darüber diskutieren
würden werden ob in deutschland
eigentlich ungeimpfte noch
sozialleistungen bekommen ist das völlig
in ordnung dass ungeimpfte hartz4
bekommen in deutschland ich finde
eindeutig ja ungeimpfte sollten hartz iv
bekommen aber sie werden diese
diskussion erleben in den nächsten
wochen die wird noch geführt würden ist
es eigentlich in ordnung dass
feuerwehrleute aus dem brennenden haus
noch in ungeimpfte retten ich finde es
ist absolut in ordnung aber ich glaube
dass wir soweit in dieser debatte
mittlerweile sind ja es ist richtig sich
impfen zu lassen es ist auch sehr
verantwortungsvoll sich impfen zu lassen
es ist mittlerweile auch ein
solidarischer gedanke weil die
krankenhäuser ebenso voll sind sich
impfen zu lassen das stimmt alles aber
dann habe ich irgendwann aktuell sind
elf prozent der intensivbetten mit
corona aber landesweit na das ist ja
immer auch referiert der
regionalreferent aber in dem das habe
ich einmal angezogen ich glaube man muss
sehr stark differenzieren zwischen mars
und des staates und entscheidungen von
mündigen und freien bürgern und sie ist
jetzt in dem fall ein wenig an freie
bürger der selber sagt ich möchte das
nicht und ich find das muss man genauso
akzeptieren wie wenn jemand sagt ich
möchte mich impfen ja aber sie möchte
noch erreichen dass der umgelegt werden
wird und sie sagt ja nicht wenn da zehn
ungeimpfte sind dann lege ich selber mal
schauspieler job danieder und warte bis
dann eine durchgehende wissen möchte
ausgesagt er arbeitet nicht mit
ungeimpften dann glaubst das ganze
selbst sagt wir verzichten auf den star
und die umkämpfte dann hat aber das
genannt werden arbeiten wir haben ja
auch genau infektionsschutzgesetz und da
steht halt drin welche regeln für alle
leute gelten im neuen entwurf den die
ampel parteien vorlegen steht eben drin
das ist ein 3g pflicht am arbeitsplatz
gibt mein traum wenn wir da nicht drehen
möchte darüber hinaus dann kann sie das
tun dann bekommt kein geld genauso wie
derjenige der aus anderen gründen eben
nicht erscheint roche der schweizer
blick rausgehalten
ich bin nach einer der ewig zuhören
können
nein also mich befremdet dass natürlich
meine das ist da steht der gar nicht zu
so etwas zu sagen wir haben eine
rechtsordnung der gelten bestimmte
regeln denn bis vor kurzem war so wenn
eine getestet ist dann konnte er voll
mitmachen sind wir jetzt eigentlich an
dem punkt wo jeder private bestimmen
kann was da läuft also kommen jetzt
plötzlich sagen ja gilt ist okay jetzt
will ich nur noch mit leute mit booster
impfung in diese sendung gehen oder mit
leuten die sich nur mit moderner
gelaufen war bei johnson johnson bin ich
nicht einverstanden
wo kommen wir denn da hin aber sie
kannst du eben nicht zustimmen
jetzt erreicht die gedruckte diskussion
was ist das motiv warum macht sie das
überhaupt was so dass ganze nahrung da
bin ich natürlich bei kai da muss ich
sagen ich meine was ist der sinn des
ganzen ich habe den verdacht dass frau
werner möchte sich jetzt einfach auf ein
bestimmtes podest stellen und sagen ich
bin dann die ganz
tolle frau da die sich der einsetzt und
so weiter und ich muss ganz ehrlich bin
auch geimpft aber ich habe das
wahnsinnig nicht gern wenn irgendwelche
leute die keine ahnung von irgendwas hat
und von medizin vor allem wenn die mir
empfehlungen machen welche medizinischen
behandlungen ich mir verabreichen soll
das nervt mich auch beim start ich
entscheide selber ob ich mich impfen
lassen oder nicht und es steht dem start
und das steht niemandem zu sich derart
in die körpersäfte eines anderen
menschen einzumischen ich erinnere daran
die haben übrigens auch ein arzneimittel
werbeverbot das hat man früher sehr
streng beachtet heute sind alles kleine
im wäre alles im pfauen pastoren und ich
finde einfach hier wäre etwas
zurückhaltung und etwas weniger
ego marketing wäre heilsam